PETE FRISELLA: Welcome.
My name's Pete Frisella.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Analytics team.
And thanks for coming, Nick.
So today we're going to talk a
little bit about the Google
Analytics metadata API, how to
use the meta data API, what
does it mean for you in terms of
development and maybe some
products that you might
be working on.
And then we'll talk a little bit
with this new thing, which
is the data deprecation
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: The metrics
represent the numbers and
numerical values.
And the dimensions represent the
strings or text that break
down the metrics on various
criteria, for example, the
source and media.
So the big question for
developers is what are the
dimensions and metrics that are
available that you can use
in the reporting APIs to
query for your data.
Now, take for example what we
have, a tool here's a query
explore what we build.
In the query explorer, we allow
users to build different
queries to query our API and get
that reporting data that
we showed earlier.
In the query explorer, we have a
section for people to select
dimensions, for them
to select metrics.
When they select them, we show
groups, all the different
dimensions and metrics.
We even show descriptions.
Now, we built this tool because
we know the product
and we work on the
product team.
But for developers building
interfaces like this in their
own product, it can be very
difficult to stay on top of
all this data.
And so what we did is we
packaged all this data and we
released it in what we call
the Metadata API.
Wit the Metadata API, you have
access to all this data
programmatically.
PETE FRISELLA: Great.
So let's just take a look
at what this looks like.
And this is an actual response
back from the Metadata API.
So we have a new endpoint
under Metadata.
And then when you provide a
report type and then the
resource is called column.
So when you actually
visit that URL--
let's back up.
You'll see the actual
response.
This is coming directly
from the server.
So we have all this--
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: So
this is a live--
PETE FRISELLA: This is live.
This just came--
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Oh, wow.
Wow, that was really fast.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
So it comes back.
And we get all this
great information
that you just described.
It's the stuff that you need
to kind of build these
[INAUDIBLE]
API or other Google reporting
APIs is the ID.
This is kind of the important
part of this.
And it represents the entire
dimension or metric.
That's the name you actually
use when you query for the
reporting data.
So in this example we have
average time on site.
That's the ID.
And that's the kind of
information you get back.
The other thing is that we've
provided all these lists of
attributes that makes sense to
have when you're trying to
build a UI.
That's just stuff that you're
going need to know.
And we can kind of group these
into different areas.
And the first area that we want
to talk about is the type
attributes.
There's two of them here.
And they provide two pieces
of information that
are obviously essential.
One is is this a dimension or
metric, which is the type
attribute that identifies
that.
And then we have
the data type.
And this lets you know, for this
particular dimension or
metric, what is the data value
that's being returned.
Is it time?
Is it maybe a percent?
Is it a float integer?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: So these are
things like formatting.
PETE FRISELLA: Exactly.
So you kind of understand what
the format of that value is.
Because when you look at JSON
response, these are all
basically strings.
And this tells you the
actual data type.
The next thing is that we
provide kind of these--
we can just think of as a
description or UI attributes.
So you'll notice that we
have these groupings
available for you.
And this is stuff
that we provide.
The Google Analytics team has
kind of grouped these
different dimensions and metrics
into kind of similar
groupings that will be
helpful when you're
building a UI, for example.
So this is that you can
use it or not use it.
But it's helpful in
that situation.
So every dimension or metric
is going to have this group
attribute just to help
you with that.
And then we also have things
like the UI name
and the app UI name.
So depending on whether you set
up a web property or an
app properly or profile, there
is certain dimensions and
metrics that have different
names depending
of it's app or web.
And if there is a particular
name for an app UI then we'll
provide this extra attribute
as part of the response for
that particular dimension
or metric.
So you want to check that when
you're using the Metadata API.
You want to check the response
to see if that exists for that
particular dimension or metric
and use that depending on
whether you're building an
app or web interface.
Then we provide description,
which just you a little
description of what the actual
dimension or metric is.
And then we provide this
additional calculation attribute.
Again, this provides more
information around if it is a
calculated metric, there's
a few that
are calculated metrics.
This will show you the actual
dimensions and other metrics
that we use to actually come
with that calculation.
So these are all very helpful
building out your UI's just as
you described.
The other things that we have,
there is particular dimensions
and metrics that have these
repeated values.
So if you have, like,
a numeric index--
so something, for example,
we have custom
dimensions and metrics.
You'll notice they have these
double x's as part of the ID.
And what that means is that
there's a particular range for
that dimension or metric.
So we provide these attributes
that give you the boundary or
the range that is valid
for this particular
dimension or metric.
And this helps you understand
either for validation purposes
or if you want to build out a
list of dimensions and metrics
that are valid for a particular
repeated value.
This will provide the
values that you
need to know for that.
And then, finally, we have some
attributes that you can
think of as helping in
terms of validation.
So we have an allow it in
segments attribute.
And this just helps you identify
whether a particular
dimension can be used in a
reporting query as a segment.
And if it is allowed then this
attribute will exist.
If not, it will not exist.
And, again, this is helpful for
validation and making sure
you're building queries out
that will work properly.
So it's a whole bunch of great
stuff in terms of the data
that we provide.
It gives you, I think, pretty
much, like, a good coverage on
all the stuff that you're going
to need to build out to
build an API.
The final thing that we're going
to talk about here in
terms of attributes is
this the ETag value.
So you'll notice when you make a
request through the Metadata
API, you'll get a response
back and
it'll be in Etag attribute.
And what this is is a unique
identifier that you can use to
determine whether the response
has changed since the last
time that you requested it.
So if you make the response and
you cache out the client
side or server side, and you
make another request later on,
if that value matches, the value
have stored, the Etag
value, that means the response
has not changed.
And this is helpful
for a few reasons.
One is if you've maybe got a
response and build out a UI,
you can use the Etag to
determine if you need to
update that UI.
Because if the value hasn't
changed then there's no point
in updating your UI because
nothing's changed since the
last time you requested it.
Another way you can use it is
when you make your request to
the Google Analytic servers, to
the Metadata API, you can
actually include this Etag value
as part of the headers.
And then the response you get
back will depend on whether
the value you provided is the
same as what already exists on
the server or it doesn't.
So if you send the Etag value
and it's the same, we'll
respond back with a 304
response, which is a not
modified response.
And then you'll know that
there's no changes.
If you provide the value and it
responds back at 200 then
that means there's a new
response and you have to
update what you have
on your server side
or your client side.
So it's really helpful
saving quota.
And this is really probably
useful for mobile because you
don't want to be sending
a lot of data back
and forth on mobile.
And actually when you make the
request to the Metadata API,
you can specify a fields
parameter and specify just to
request the Etag value
if you'd like.
So it's really useful for
caching and making efficient
use of the API and quota.
So let's talk a little
bit about the
data deprecation policy.
This is new, right?
We introduced this?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yes.
One other thing that we're
introducing with the Metadata
API is a new data deprecation
policy.
And this covers how we add and
change data within Google
Analytics reporting APIs.
So when we add new data,
we'll announce it
through the change log.
And then the data will
automatically appear through
the Metadata API.
So if you're actually building
any products using this API,
they'll automatically be
updated, which is fantastic.
The second thing is when we
decide to remove data-- in the
past we would announce it, but
there was nothing formal.
So today we're formalizing
it with this API.
When we announce a deprecation
of data, what we'll do is
we'll actually messes
the change logs.
And then it will be available
for a minimum of six months,
after which we'll remove it.
And what we're doing is to
message user interfaces, to
keep them updated, where it's
actually a new status
parameter that we'll set
to deprecate it.
By default, it's public.
And so once it's deprecated, you
can actually update your
interfaces to start
changing them.
And then finally in the cases
where we want to replace,
sometimes we'll rename a
different dimension and
metric, this will also go
through deprecation.
We'll announce the change
on a change log.
The old name will be available
for a minimum of six months.
But we'll also introduce a brand
new parameter that's
called the replaced
by parameter.
And it actually returns an ID
that points to a different
entity that's the replacement,
a different dimension or
metric that's the replacement
for the one that's being
deprecated.
So what's great about it is now,
with the Metadata API,
for products that have
integrated with it, they
completely can be compliant
with all our deprecation
policies without having to
push new releases to
production.
So let's take a look at some
of these attributes.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah, see
how it manifests
in the actual response.
So you'll see that there's a few
different attributes here
that Nick mentioned, which
was the status.
So when this gets deprecated,
this will change from public
to deprecated.
And you should always be
checking for this value to
make sure that the dimensions
and metrics you're using are
still valid and can be
used in a query.
And if it does change to
deprecated then you definitely
want to be checking to see if
it's been replaced, maybe buy
a different ID.
And if that's the case then
we'll also include this
replaced by attribute, which
then points the ID of
obviously the dimension or
metric that's replacing this
particular one.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yeah.
And I think the good thing about
this is that many people
will build save reports within
their products and interfaces.
So if you do see something
that's deprecated, you will
want to make sure you go back
and update or warn your users
that either the queries will
stop working in the future or
just go ahead and update them
with the replaced by so that
way they don't see any
disruption of service.
PETE FRISELLA: Yeah.
And if you don't do this,
ultimately at some point it'll
be removed and you'll get a
bad request response back.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yeah.
And it'll be a bad user
experience as well.
PETE FRISELLA: Yes, exactly.
OK, great.
So we covered a lot.
But it's a very simple but
powerful API, I think.
So it's really easy to use and
it's really powerful in terms
of what you can do in the
UI and stuff like that.
We do have a lot of resources
available if you'd like to
learn more about this API
and how to use it.
We provide some code snippets
and examples on our developer
site as per usual.
And, again, if you're going to
use it, register in the APIs
console and get an
API key that you
can throw it together.
And then we have a new data
deprecation policy that we
encourage you to read
and review.
So if you're building
applications, you'll
understand how things will
be changed in the future.
So that's it for today.
We wanted to keep it
short and simple.
And we want to thank you
for joining us again.
And we hope to see
you next time.
Thank you very much.